all right juan division another episode
of one division also spoiler alert for
one division this week that would be
episode five of one division also
spoiler alert for any previous episodes
of one division
and avengers infinity war we've all seen
that let's not get ridiculous here so
now
after last week we've seen the peak
behind the curtain we've seen well i
mean
it's funny that the peak behind the
curtain is just
the real world but we're seeing how
sword is dealing with the situation of
the wanda vision universe and so now
we're spending equal time
there and in the one division universe
so it's splitting the time up
in that we found out yeah wanda just
broke into this facility
took vision's body something he did not
want but you know
the heart wants what the heart wants and
sometimes the heart wants to have dead
robot sex with your dead robot boyfriend
and
do a whole weekend at bernie's but a
sitcom hey you only live once right so
actually i have to address this i know
it freaked a lot of you out i didn't
mention
dead zombie robot vision from last
week's episode
because it didn't really freak me out so
much i just felt like i'd seen that done
before you know that whole thing like
how you doing oh
i'm great thanks great oh by the way
hey what is it i just i've seen that
kind of stuff before i mean now we know
that she is in fact
having dead robot sex with vision but
let's face it sex robots already exist
we're all gonna be having dead robot sex
with any number of
robot bodies here in the near future so
let's not make it weird i find it
interesting that agnes broke character
you know it's
when the twins were in the crib she was
like oh shoot did you want me to want me
to hold them
yeah it i mean it looked like outtakes
from a sitcom or
but less fun usually outtakes from
sitcoms have people cheering and
laughing it just looked
awkward but it looked like an awkward
line fumble
from bonus features or something but
when vision touched that dude's brain
he's like help me she's evil it's like
whoa that brings me to a thing i really
liked in this episode is i see
wanda as a villain for the first time
since age of ultron but even in age of
ultron by the end of that movie she
wasn't a villain anymore but now i
see her as a villain granted it's in
that breaking bad kind of way it's like
i know your story i know
why you're doing it i get the pain but
still
you are the villain of this situation
road to hell is paved with good
intentions that is a concept as old as
humanity itself so although
you get that you still be like well you
are still enslaving this entire town and
making them
what your mental puppets for your little
sitcom you wanted to the whole town's
like
i'm powerless by the way could i borrow
some ice cubes
there are strings on me oh [ __ ] that's
kind of funny there are no strings on me
it's a song from the
age of ultron trailer the trailer for
the movie that
wanda maximoff that was her movie well
[ __ ] we've just hit another level of
irony well that scene was [ __ ] boss
which she just
walks through the force field and she's
like hey is this drone yours like her
accent's back she's like
stay out of my way or i'll suck your
blood
i mean just paraphrasing a couple
episodes passed her accent broke i think
it was when
monica rambo was like oh [ __ ] what's all
this and your brother
quicksilver he died i think it was that
situation but there was a situation
where her accent crept back
and i thought i heard that and i was
like i was probably hearing stuff and
the internet's like holy [ __ ] did you
hear the accent come back it's like [ __ ]
i should have said that your eyes can
deceive you don't trust them
your ears on the other hand i never said
a thing about that i always trust your
ears yeah there's a pretty boss
situation where she was like just stay
the [ __ ] out of my way by the way
all the guns pointing at commander
douche peace love what's the end game
though how far
is this going to go is this going to be
like decade by decade until
you know the next episode should be in
the 90s in which
she should be like by the way vision
amazon
trust me and the best part is i'm not
even alone in seeing her as a villain
because vision's starting to as well
vision's really starting to question
stuff he's like wanda what are you doing
everyone in this town you're holding
them hostage they're in pain
stop vision's like what's out there
what's in the world out there and she's
like nothing good that's a world where
people will cancel star-lord
for fake tweets he didn't even make they
were
photoshopped vision [ __ ] that place i'm
staying right here i just love seeing
the tension between
vision and wanda look like superman and
zod just
ready to trash his town which tells me
although vision doesn't
remember experiencing death per se he's
about to experience something far worse
than death
and that is having a psycho x
but and this is well this is one of
those moments where it's like damn it
internet because
the doorbell rings and then she answers
the door and you see the back
of someone's head and i was like oh evan
peters is in this show and there he is
evan peters has quicksilver which is
actually
really clever because it's dealing with
a tv show and
it's a different quicksilver it's i give
marvel this they're really good at
taking a situation and
fixing it with billions of dollars but
you know taking a situation and then
being like all right we're just gonna
roll with it make it part of the
universe oh x-men we're at that studio
and we had this studio there were two
different quicksilvers one
in marvel canon died the other one is
part of the characters that marvel now
owns because they bought fox what to do
with that
it makes sense for the context of one
division i thought that was really
clever but again damn it internet
because i watch youtube videos as much
as the next person
sometimes the internet's like hey you
watched how the universe works
here's a suggestion evan peters in one
division i didn't even watch the video i
just
saw the thumbnail and the title and that
was that would have liked that to
remain the surprise it was supposed to
be but the moment i saw the back of his
head i was like
oh yeah that's right he's in this so i
just gotta you know not go online but i
thought that was really cool i'm really
interested to see what they do with it
if it
ends with him if there's more i've heard
there's gonna be the surprise cameo in
wand division
who's it gonna be i mean was he it
because i already knew about
him so it's got to be someone else right
i already know who it is i mean you just
look at the names
folks we already know what are the twins
names tommy and billy
obviously it's a power rangers crossover
come on in the end this episode of
wandavision it ramped it up it's
springboards
off of last week's episode which had my
curiosity
this week had my [ __ ] attention but
they're in a unique and interesting
position to do some really cool stuff
especially with how this episode ended
so i'm just
i'm along for the ride all right so this
week's episode of wand division one
division episode five have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to say more
[Music]
you